c'est en janvier 2002 que le
milliardaire michael bloomberg a pris
les rênes de la ville de new york sous
la bannière républicaine
à 59 ans il succédait ainsi à rudi
giuliani et devenait le maire de l'après
11 septembre il aura même réussi à
convaincre ses concitoyens de changer
les règles afin qu'ils puissent se
représenter comme air pour une troisième
fois cette fois ci comme indépendants
bloomberg a d'abord fait fortune dans
les années 80 en créant une agence
d'informations financières qui porte son
nom
aujourd'hui à la tête d'une fortune de
40 milliards de dollars
il serait la dixième personne la plus
riche du monde
politiquement c'est un ancien démocrate
mais toujours un progressiste il est
pour le droit à l'avortement pour le
mariage des conjoints de même sexe pour
la citoyenneté pour les immigrants
illégaux ainsi qu'en faveur d'un plus
grand contrôle des armes à feu
chaque année son clip
conscient du réchauffement climatique il
a été le promoteur des efforts pour
réduire les gaz à effet de serre dans la
grosse pomme mais sur le plan économique
c'est un conservateur est un bon
gestionnaire qui plaît beaucoup aux
républicains ces parcours suit le profil
d'un potentiel chef d'état même s'ils
s'en laisse souvent défendu en
plaisantant que le petit juif
milliardaire divorcée qui l'est n'aurait
aucune chance pour la présidence
entrera-t-il malgré tout cette fois ci
dans la périlleuse danse vers la maison
blanche
réponse dans les prochaines semaines
grübel ne serait pas le premier candidat
indépendant à briguer la présidence
américaine
frédéric il y a dans l'histoire récente
des etats-unis exemple plutôt s'élèvent
d'ailleurs
et oui le premier d'entre eux c'est
évidemment le bild le milliardaire texan
ross pérot qui s'est présenté deux fois
en 92 ans 96 92 comme indépendant 96
sous la bannière du parti réformiste
mais regardez 192 vraiment qu'il a eu un
résultat assez a assez imposant regardez
plutôt le résultat en fait il a réussi à
les chercher 19 pour cent du vote
populaire c'est énorme évidemment et on
pense que c'est ça qui a fait pencher la
balance plus du côté de monsieur clinton
qui l'a finalement emporté
devant monsieur bush qui cherchait un
deuxième mandat autre cas ces rafles et
2,4 fois il s'est présenté la présidence
américaine
parfois comme indépendant parfois sous
l'étiquette du parti vert est regardée
en 2000 ce qui s'est passé 2 7% s'est
pas beaucoup mais c'est probablement ce
qui a aidé à gagner monsieur bush
notamment en floride face à al gore
aujourd'hui 2016 highcroft dida
indépendant qui gagnerait la
présidentielle ce serait quand même
exceptionnel c'est très difficile
d'abord parce qu'il faut être inscrit
sur les bulletins de vote des 50 états
il faut beaucoup d'argent ce qui
peut-être pas un problème pour monsieur
blue bird qui serait prêt à dépenser un
milliard de dollars mais vous savez aux
etats unis c'est pas tellement le vote
populaire qui est important c'est le
vote des grands électeurs c'est toujours
un direct la mer aux états unis les
électeurs vont voter pour des
représentants qui ensuite vont voter
pour le candidat à la présidence est
donc il ya des chiffres magiques et
avoir ce notamment sur les 538 grands
électeurs il en faut au moins 270 c'est
quasiment impossible pour des
indépendants qui n'ont pas forcément de
machines électorales comme les
démocrates et des républicains pour
aller chercher ce chiffre magique
résultat mais on reste encore plus que
probablement dans un système politique à
deux parties et c'est tout alors pour
l'instant monsieur bloomberg s'est pas
officiel donc on va attendre encore un
peu absolument à suivre